one of the things that's definitive in
order to build something in a factory or
in the theoretical you need absolute
information because it absolutely has to
match uh the theoretical when you're
building in the factory and it
absolutely has to get installed based on
that theoretical so all the technology
associated with that is helpful IE um
for instance the the the dimensional
accuracy is easily measured by robotic
uh robotic surve Etc you can test it
against theoretical and get variances in
seconds uh which used to take forever
and frankly really couldn't meet the
accuracy that's one
[Music]
thing Roger krulac welcome to 20 minute
leaders I'm so excited to have you for
another episode here uh bringing thought
leaders domain experts innovators and
entrepreneurs uh uh to inspire us all
with with what you're what you're
spending most of your time on and why
you're so excited about what you're
doing so so thank you Roger for for
taking the time here H tell me a little
bit about ER tell me a little bit about
yourself and your work um Michael thank
you so much for the invitation it's an
honor to be here
today and let me tell you a little bit
about fullstack
fullstack is a fully
biometric modular solution very focused
on Urban environment mid to
highrise uh so hotels student housing
dormitories uh that's the that's the
majority of our business so the the word
modular what that has a significant
impact what does that mean here in this
context such a good question I'm not
actually sure modular means anything
anymore it's been so overused it's sort
of like Kleenex or tissue it doesn't
really mean anything so let me let me
spend two seconds explaining what it is
so the word modular has too many
applications and and um there was a
great report done by McKenzie sort of
2019 is that explained the
differentiation between it it's a good
resource if somebody wants to take a
look at it but in short all kinds of
things are considered
modular panelized construction pre-cast
concrete parking lots um curtain Wall
Systems the whole lot of things are
called modular and then a whole bunch of
supply chain is now picked up the word
modular so it it's lost really what a
definition of what it is but what
fullstack modum does is fully
biometric
modular Integrated Solutions that are
fully volumetric boxes fully fit out
fully distributed and very focused on
the urban process and the Singaporean
named it prefabricated pre-finished
volumetric construction which I think is
a very good definition but far too
complicated for anyone to pick up in the
United States but it's very accurate and
that's what we do incredible and so and
and so you've been at this for a while I
mean you're you have family background
also in the space what what has been
really the core evolution of real estate
and construction from your perspective
so the construction space certainly the
built environment especially as it
relates to housing is
in flux and transition the reality is is
that the current industry the way it's
organized certainly in the United States
and other places is unable to meet the
market need significantly both from a
cost perspective and from an output
perspective and
so um volumetric modle of construction
that pack engages in is one Avenue to
try to increase the throughput and meet
the need uh in a way that is you know
creative to to diminishing the you know
the the market Gap and so that's really
what FST has been focused on at least
for the last five years how do we
provide a solution that meets the market
need and and so is it is it really all
about scale or are there different
considerations for for why to do this
yeah you you asked me a very simple
question that's a very complicated
answer the answer to your question is um
is that just like the stock market the
construction Market is very volatile in
its uh in its increase and decrease in
pricing and it's basically based on
current market needed at a specific time
and as a result of that it's pretty
lumpy you know projects take a long time
to get approved there are government uh
holdups there's financing holdups right
now you know Vel opers for example are
buying distressed properties rather than
building new because the market value is
uh is higher for that at the moment that
you know the the um the cap rates are
Are Climbing so uh because interest
rates are also climbing and so as a
result of that um you have a pause in
sort of concerted development or at
least in most places
so one option that we have put forward
is is that you can use industrialization
which is used in almost every other
industry other than construction
including all the pieces and parts that
go into construction or the built
environment
and in order to incorporate the
economies of scale that are created by
industrialization you need steady flow
right so workflow or single piece flow
as is almost every is required in order
to be highly efficient what you do
so you have a dichotomous goal right so
developers don't want to build until the
market is right and they want it to flow
in a way that works for them from a IR
or return perspective which is
absolutely the right thing to do and
sometimes that creates a lumpy situation
where throughput is unpredictable then
you have an industrialization effort
which wants constant flow so how do you
mix the two in a way that is accretive
to to the end goals and that is in short
the problem um uh you know technology
can help increase productivity increase
accuracy increase quality but until
factories are busy all the time um you
you have an you have an overhead Gap up
problem you have a um a learning problem
industrialization requires that you have
somewhat repetitive work happening over
and over again so you get economies of
scale so if it's lumpy the learning
slows down the the throughput slows down
and as a result of that the cost doesn't
get significantly better so um you know
average developer calls full stack or
any other modular manufacturer op and
say how much does it cost to build a
120,000 foot building in X
location
and although we can answer that question
the value proposition isn't really met
unless you have constant throughput so
that you can manufacture it if you can
manufacture cars or telephones or rocket
ships or airplanes as long as your QA QC
is good it's fine uh but if you can't do
that then you don't get all of the value
that you literally plan from an
industrialized process the other part of
it which is worth noting is that
traditionally in this country we have
been a design bid build process C
whereby you come up with the design you
send it out to a bunch of general
contractors and their Associated sub
trades and you get a price for something
that's already baked uh which is
relatively inefficient we have as an
industry just taken the lowest bidder
regardless of the the scope gaps
associated with it and our big you know
sort of gc's and construction managers
have gotten very Savvy at trying to
level bids and now what we're doing is
we're inserting
a process that really wants to move to a
design build process which where
everybody's sitting at the table with
the goals defined at the beginning
that's a big industry shift and that's
what's happening right now and by the
way it's not only happening with modular
it's happening you know public and
private institutions are now starting I
won't say Embrace they're starting to
accept the fact that design build offers
opportunities that you can't get with
design bid building and as a result of
that willingness to shift the industry
is also
benefiting H how is technology impacting
all of this so everything that's
happening with AI with software with
planning 3D Landscaping I mean how how
how are things changing from your
experience now all all kinds of
opportunity in the AI world so one of
the things that's definitive in order to
build something in a factory or in the
theoretical you need absolute
information because it absolutely has to
match uh the theoretical when you're
building in the factory and it
absolutely has to get installed based on
that theoretical so all the technology
associated with that is helpful IE um
for instance the the the dimensional
accuracy is easily measured by robotic
uh robotic surveying Etc you can test it
against theoretical and get variances in
seconds uh which used to take forever
and frankly really couldn't meet the
accuracy that's one thing the other
thing is is
that because like every manufacturing
process we have sort of moderately to
less skilled labor we need to give very
specific instructions and to create very
spe Specific Instructions for a building
that's you know 150,000
fet is thousands and thousands and
thousands of
pages with AI you can come up with a G
game plan you can create a a sort of
prototype solution uh then you can list
its variables and then you can have an
AI program just run all the drawings and
then you just need to qaqc them and see
if it's if if your rules it's not even
on the computer it's if the rules were
accurate or the rules were inaccurate
and as a result of that you can end up
with very rapidly Deployable production
processes so those two things for sure
and right now we we've been actually um
working with an AI program that actually
takes modular parameters and also zoning
information and then combines the two to
see multiple variables of the building
you could build on that site using your
parameters in seconds so all of those
things uh could talk a lot more about
sort of Automation in the industrialized
space but all those things are making it
easier as a team to create Sol solutions
that work and are identifiable costable
predictable very cool I mean one of the
things that I'm always very intrigued by
and curious about is is the
transformation that AI has on
traditional Industries on on industries
that are are you know here they've been
around for a while there's you know they
serve some very fundamental necessities
of of people of our life like the places
we work and the places we live right and
so um so so besides the planning where
else do you see technology software AI
integrating into the workflow of of of
the work that you're doing where where
are the big I guess not even what's
coming up next because who knows but but
what are the big pain points that you're
still observing that you're saying wow
here are really tremendous opportunities
that that people can can leverage if
they have great technology well I think
I identified bunch of them uh and and
and those are significant in that they
are solving for what is it that we are
going to do quickly so that's uh because
obviously that's way better than you can
get in a design good build process of
course in addition to that there is the
opportunity to automate physical tasks
certainly on a low hanging
fruit process so that you can provide
robot code AS instructions in L of sort
of Specific Instructions to a
human and the
opportunity there excuse
me the opportunity there is to increase
productivity of the workforce because
the repetitive work can be augmented by
some level of Automation and the
information that's coming out of the
design process is translatable machine
code for example and that's a huge
opportunity the other thing that it does
is it
provides pretty
easy calculation of what it costs what
the expected productivity time is how
long it is you know our industry
different from the conventional
construction industry is really time
material and overhead you know like any
manufacturer so when you can increase
productivity you decrease your cost and
when you have more throughput you
decrease your overhead so those are the
those are the
the the paradigms we play with and you
know s sort of enhanced human
productivity by virtue of utilizing the
technologies that are available is
valuable really interesting if you think
towards the future a little bit about
how our our spaces we look our our homes
our buildings are there shifts happening
in the way we're thinking through our
living situation
and environments I mean is this even a
something that's in discussion or did we
nail it I mean are we you know are we at
sort of the the the peak or where are we
in this in the evolution of of
optimizing our space well I don't think
we really know what optimization of our
space means yet because I think we are
in a shift right now I mean obviously as
as you described you know covid changed
a lot of things right you know work at
home
uh as part of your work process um what
kind of space as a result of that we
need as human beings and expect um is
there um motivation to move into a dense
Urban environment or is there a shift to
you know sort of secondary or tertiary
cities and what does that mean from a
quality and housing perspective and then
you can shift to you know how interested
are we to have our built environment be
responsive to things like climate change
sustainability all the and all of those
things the reality is is that we we are
just starting to measure how our
buildings perform and I don't think we
really yet have an accurate way of
calculating the effect you know what the
and we've done lots of exercises on it
and so have many many people like what
is the what is the removal of carbon
from the process that you're doing in
relation to a baseline but the problem
is is that we don't really have many
baselines so we're still learning how to
measure which I think is the first step
and then once we measure we'll be able
to we'll be able to improve that process
So my answer to your question is I don't
think it's a one thing we've nailed it
because I think that we are evolving you
know sort of in what we want you know if
you want to cure climate change it's
pretty simple right you create as dense
a population as you can with all the
services proxim to what they're doing
organize the work around those people
and um and put it all in one building
that is highly
sustainable you're going to have huge
impact on carbon footprint of all the
people in that building and the building
itself but we're not necessarily doing
that and you know for years and I mean
40 years people have been urging
certainly in the United States
developers to think about secondary
costs or long-term cost costs of a
choice to say be slightly less
sustainable or lower construction costs
on the beginning because obviously that
drives irr but what happens to the
building over time how how hard is it
to capture the cost Savings of say for
instance you know efficient
operation uh as opposed to sort of
conventional operation and how much can
you save and what's the second cost with
it and we still we're still in that
process we're getting way better at it
but we're still there we're still in
that process very very cool Roger to
wrap us up what has been the most
enjoyable aspect for you in working and
leading in the space so what what part
of this of your work of of this category
really brings you Joy inspiration
fulfillment yeah I mean look I uh I'm a
huge believer that people should have a
place to live if uh if it's seems to be
like it's a right that's not necessarily
delivered and um our efforts to
industrialize the built environment
especially focused on housing because
that's really our space albeit multif
family um the idea of creating that and
providing that as an
opportunity um is is drives me so
whether it's you know working on
affordable housing or student dorms or
you know places for people to stay while
they're building you know the us is
building tons of manufacturing capacity
but very few places that are building
the manufacturing capacity have housing
available so like we it's helping solve
a puzzle that we created ourselves which
can be great for the United States in
the long run but we've got lots of
problems to solve and this is one of
them so I like being in the mix of of
that incredible Roger I really want to
thank you thank you for taking the time
to be here and for sharing this uh
conversation with me
different H another different category
another different landscape but but
again excited and passionate
entrepreneur in yourself so thank you
again for this time and I'm excited to
share this with everybody thank you
thank you Michael for the time today
really appreciate it thank you